[Music]
we have created a product that is the
most deliberate middle finger to the
media establishment ever designed
ceramic to town with a child rim and
hand etched finish this product grants
those who wielded entry into the most
exclusive club in all the universe
aluminum a louder with crowd and MA Club
will change the way you view the world
where possibilities are now endless were
various a distant memory and hashtag
never daily transforms into a new daily
program fish and chips with Steve is
free to the unfiltered uncensored and
even capable of gross abuses of the FCC
guidelines and not gay Jared's physical
body on live broadcast proudly
introducing the muddler
well I'm sorry yeah yeah yeah no I'm
narrating something fancy like Hello
leave a bit bigger yeah I'm now right
proudly introduce the new daily program
the louder was crowd and Mugler aims to
elevate the human experience it's just
what the right a lot it's distracting
one corner now right or no commercial
[Music]
that's right
I lied well I didn't lie I was genuinely
hashtag never daily but my exploratory
committee told me that it was necessary
out of demand from you the viewer so we
are officially announcing the louder
with Crowder mug club for our daily
program register louder with credit calm
slash mug Club today and not only do you
get a Daily Show from me you get a
weekly show from not gey Jared but you
also get access to the entire CR TV
network mark levin Mark Steyn Michelle
Malkin we've been thinking about doing
this for a while but we wanted to do it
in a way that made sense we didn't want
to do a patreon and ask you for money we
wanted to provide you with so much
value-added that you'd be happy to do it
so for 99 dollars for the year or if
you're a student I enter in the promo
code student lowercase and you get it
for $69 that's less than six dollars a
month you get access to all of those
shows and you can't even just hear this
hand etched mug now to some of you who
may be concerned listen there's no
bait-and-switch everything that's free
now is still free as a matter of fact
even more so the once a week show is
still free videos actually will probably
have videos every day because we'll be
taking them from the the daily show are
free the daily articles all the stuff on
Facebook Twitter all that is still free
you can just join the mug club or join
the CR TV network if you want to get the
full-length
daily show we want to be your last show
of the night we want you to watch us at
night unwind learn about politics for
the day and only join if you want to
watch The Daily Show but it also allows
us to create more free content to go
fight the left in their own backyard
here on YouTube and on Facebook so you
get all that entertainment value and you
also help employ everyone who works here
at la doors Crowder Courtney
Casey Brautigan Corey Jared Aaron
Francine and we're going to be hiring
another few that'll be another golden
ticket sweepstakes because we're growing
listen a lot of you have said someone
needs to create an alternative platform
to YouTube or Facebook we don't want to
do that we still want to be here we
still want to be changing hearts and
minds we have hundreds of millions of
plays and reads and downloads what this
allows us to do is create more content
more value for you and still fight the
left in their own backyard on all these
places and still
reach new people so I know you've seen
with this election the experts people
who looked down who other the rest of
America they thought they had a speed
and they were pushing and prodding and
they don't know what they've been asking
for this is the time people are aware of
how corrupt the media is and there's a
void and we are going to take it back
louder with credit calm / mug Club you
won't be disappointed
you tell them Crowder's gone daily and
hell's coming with me you hear hell's
coming with me